[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN PAIK: Hi everyone.
My name is Dan Paik.
I'm a product manager on the
Google Container Engine team.
So I work with Container
Engine as well as Kubernetes.
And today I'd like to give
you a quick introduction
to container development in
the Google Cloud Platform.
I want to show you how
easy it is to write
and deployed code
using containers
with the various tools
that are available to you
on the Google Cloud Platform.
We'll go over using tools
such as Google Cloud Shell,
the Google Container Registry.
And of course we'll also go
over Container Engine, as well.
The main thing is that
the Google Cloud Platform
has all the tools available
for you to get started
with container development.
We'll go over Google
Container Engine,
and where it fits within
the overall landscape
of the product offerings across
the Google Cloud Platform.
Google Container Engine
runs open-source Kubernetes
which was started by Google
to manage and orchestrate
containers.
It's a very powerful tool.
And I hope to be showcasing a
lot of that power to you today.
I'll also run through
an example and demo
of writing a simple
application, containerizing it.
We'll push the image over
to the Container Registry.
And we'll really start running
and scaling the application
with Google Container Engine.
After manually
building a container
and deploying it,
which is really simple,
I'll show you a quick demo on
how to use Helm, the Kubernetes
package manager.
To even more quickly
and easily deploy
containers for some of the
most common applications,
such as WordPress, my
SQL, Redis, and many more.
And finally, as you
continue your journey
into container development,
hopefully you'll
be building more and more
complex applications.
And as you start building more
of these complex applications
they almost always require
the use of persistent volumes
to manage, allocate,
and bind storage.
And this needs to be
done the Kubernetes way.
So I'll go through that as well.
Now, if we look at
the various product
offerings within the
Google Cloud Platform,
this is really where
Container Engine fits in.
And on the one side
with Compute Engine,
you have infrastructure
as a service.
This is where you use VMs,
you configure your disks,
you configure networking.
And in many ways,
Compute Engine is
what many people think
about when they first talk
about using Cloud technology.
Container Engine is
containers as a service.
As I mentioned earlier, it
runs open source Kubernetes.
And it's really able to manage
and orchestrate your containers
using Kubernetes.
All you really do as an
engineer or developer running
on Container Engine is
you manage your pods,
and you replicate your pods,
and you create a cluster,
and you manage nodes.
But you don't have to
manage the underlying
VMs, underlying networking,
the underlying storage,
that you would normally have
to do with Compute Engine.
All of that Compute Engine
stuff is what Container Engine
takes care of for you.
And if we go sort of even
further with App Engine,
if many of you are
familiar with App Engine,
App Engine is a further
level of abstraction,
where it's really
convenient, cause
as an engineer and a
software developer,
all you have to think
about is writing the code,
deploying code.
And everything else
is really taken care
of for you, all the scaling.
So that's kind of the scale of
different parts that we have.
In addition, we
also have products
such as Cloud Functions,
which are serverless,
and that sort of goes
even beyond App Engine
in terms of abstraction.
So let's go through
coding the container way.
So we're going to get
started by actually
writing a simple application.
We're going to containerize it.
We're going to run it in
Google Container Engine.
And I'll walk through
this first and then
I'll show you a demo of all of
this actually working, right?
So let's take a look here.
First, we have a
simple server.js file.
Hopefully most of you that
are software engineers
can sort of see what
this is doing here.
All we're really doing is
we're listening to port 8080.
And as we get a
response into port 8080
we write, hello world.
It's a node.js
database application.
And normally, you know,
you'd write code like this,
and you would type in node space
server dot js, test your code,
make sure everything
looks good, right?
But this is really sort
of before containers
what we would normally do in
a situation like that, right?
But let's say we want to
containerize this, right?
And in this example, we'll use
the Docker container runtime,
right?
So for Docker container
runtime we need a Docker file.
And all we've really
done here is we've said,
well, we want to use
Node version 4.0.
We want to expose port 8080.
The source file
server, the server.js
that we talked about before.
And the command is we just
want to run Node space dot
server.js.
So that's a simple Docker file.
And the next step,
it really is, well,
let's go build the
container image.
So if we're going to build the
container image around this
we'll use these Docker
commands to build images.
And then we'll also
use Docker commands,
and the G Cloud command to
actually push this image
to the Google
Container Registry.
Now, the Google
Container Registry
is a managed, private
container registry
that's run and operated in
the Google Cloud Platform.
So you can use that.
Now, there are other
managed, private
registries out there as well.
Or you can even set up your
own private registry just
for your organization,
for the containers
that you may use within
your organization as well.
So let's actually demo this.
And I can show you this
working in person, right?
In the back let's move over to--
I think this is
number two of the--
[INAUDIBLE] my port here.
OK.
So here I've just logged into
the Google Cloud Platform.
This is our console.
And yeah, I guess I have
some meetings going on.
So what we see here is
I've simply logged in.
I'm using Google
Cloud Shell, which
you can get to simply by
clicking that button there.
So this is a shell that's
running within the Google Cloud
Platform.
It's pretty convenient.
This may not be the way that
you would do development
on a regular basis.
Like on a regular basis, you'll
probably use your own laptops.
And you'll run Kubernetes and
the G Cloud commands directly.
But you know, for this
demo I'll use Cloud Shell.
And it's very convenient
because if you don't happen
to have your laptop
with you, or if you
want to have a quick
environment up and running,
this is always there
for you, right?
So I created a directory
here called Hello Node.
If we kind of take a
look at this directory,
I'll take a look at server.js.
And this is a file that we
kind of looked at earlier.
It's the same file there.
And as I did over there, if I
type in node space server.js,
now the file is
actually running.
Well it's supposed
to be running.
Whenever we have
these live demos
we always end up having these
kind of issues even though--
let's take a look at server.js.
Make sure it looks good.
It's always fun.
AUDIENCE: Socket's
already in use.
DAN PAIK: Oh, Socket's
OK.
Keep going.
So I'm going to
actually just build
this as a Docker
container next, which
basically is this command.
So we'll take a look
at that Docker command.
And I'll actually compile
this and run this.
This is a Docker file that
we also looked at earlier.
If we actually build it now the
Docker file has actually run,
and we've built the
Docker file itself--
I'm going to actually run
this as a Docker container.
And what you see here is like,
the first thing that we did
was we actually ran this
as a container there.
And the second thing that I
did was I actually called this,
and we see the Hello
World coming up.
So it's actually running
as a Docker container.
We can do some things here, like
if you're familiar with Docker,
we can run Docker PS
to see what's running.
We see that we have Hello
Tutorial running here.
And if we run Docker,
like stop hello tutorial,
then it will stop the
Docker process from running.
So we have a couple of things
like that that we can actually
do here within the Docker
process there, right?
So there you have it.
What we've done at
this point is we've
taken a program that we
wrote, the server.js file,
the simple node.js file.
We've actually containerized it.
And we actually
ran it in Docker.
So we ran the curl command.
So now we know that, hey,
our code actually works,
and the containerized version
of our code actually works.
So pretty good there.
But you know, the problem now
is, I mean, running a container
and building a container with
Docker is pretty easy to do.
And it's pretty convenient.
And Docker gives you a lot
of pretty cool tools there.
But the next step is if you want
to run this type of container
in a production
environment, well, now we
have to think about a
lot of other things.
We have to think about,
how would you scale this?
How do you update this how?
Do we handle rolling updates
that we plug this into a CI/CD
the type of framework?
And to manage your
containers in that sense.
This is where we need
Kubernetes to come in.
So this is where Kubernetes can
come in and actually manage,
and orchestrate our
containers for us, right?
So what I'm going to
do now is I'm actually
going to create a pod.
The same pod running,
the same image running,
except the difference
this time is
I'm actually going to
run this in Kubernetes
and have it managed
by Kubernetes, right?
So that's actually
all I'm doing here,
is I'm actually
running this as a node
that I'm creating in
Kubernetes with that image.
And what we see here is
I'm running this as--
the container's being
created right now.
And if we sort of keep going up
with this we'll see that hey,
this is running.
Now that we have a node
running with a single pod,
running a single container we
have this Hello node, you can
kind of see here that it starts
with the numbers 4222, that's
kind of just the unique
name that's been assigned
to our Node here, right?
The other thing
that I want to do
is I actually want to test this
using a browser that externally
available.
So I'm going to expose this.
So what this command
here does is this
will basically expose the--
I'll copy all of these--
but this will actually
expose our node
through Kubernetes
to the outside world.
So the other thing that
I also wanted to do here
was I said, you know, I want to
add a little bit of redundancy
here, a little bit
of replication,
and I want to make sure
that our pods stay up
and running for a long time.
So I'm going to set
four replicas here.
So in this sense,
instead of having
one pod running as a single
pod, we have four running.
So now we've scaled this
application a little bit.
We're running in four pods.
We see here that, you
know, out of the four,
there was one
running from before.
And we have three more
that are running there.
And if we do a kube
control get pods,
we'll see that, hey, all four
of them are running now, right?
So now we have this process
set up with four pods running.
Let me go check to see if our
IP address is available yet.
So what it does here is the
Hello node services that I set,
that other command
that I showed up here.
This expose command
says, hey, I want
to expose my Hello node
here to the outside world,
so give me an
external IP address.
And so it's just pending.
Now that it's no
longer pending, we
have an external
IP address here.
So I'm going to go
to that external IP
address in another window.
We'll hit port
8080, and hopefully
we actually see our Hello
World Coming up, right?
So now we actually have our
container that we wrote.
That node.js, that simple
Hello World container.
We've containerized it.
And we actually have Kubernetes
managing these containers now.
And we have four
of them running.
So far so good.
You know, looks like everything
is working pretty well.
It's replicated.
So if for whatever reason
a pod were to go down,
Kubernetes is going to keep
trying to get four running.
If you notice in that command
that I wrote up here earlier
by setting replicas to four
all I've really done here
is-- you know, I didn't
mess with the config file
or anything like that.
I just said, hey, I want
four replicas running.
And Kubernetes are smart enough
to make sure that there's
always four running.
We actually have a demo
upstairs called Whack-A-Pod
where, you know, we have
nine of these pods running.
And every time you keep trying
to whack one of the moles there
it's going to bring a pod down.
But Kubernetes is going to
keep trying to keep all nine up
and running.
So you can see how
fast Kubernetes
is at continually making
sure that your pods are
up and running.
So here we have four running.
But let's say I want to
make a change, right?
I mean, you know, all of us
that are in software development
knows that, hey, code doesn't
sort of stay stagnant.
So we're going to
go in here, we're
going to go server.js again.
This time, you know, we
really want to say, hey,
I don't really like Hello World.
I want to actually change
this to something else, right?
So let's change this to
Hello Party People, right?
So we're all party
people here, I hope.
And now I changed
the code there.
So now what happens
in the case, right?
So this is really where
Kubernetes starts to excel,
right?
Like we've updated our code.
What we want to
do now is we want
to rebuild our container image.
We want to push
our container image
to the Container Registry.
And then we want to
update our Hello node
to the new version of code.
So I'll do that right now.
The quick commands can do that.
We go right here where we have
a Docker build command here.
And then we have this.
And then I'll sort
of do all that.
So first section is
we build the image.
We actually push the image up.
This next command here,
right here, which is kube
controls set image deployment.
Hello node.
Set it to the new V2 version
of the container registry image
that we just pushed up.
So that's essentially
what we're doing there.
If I get the
deployment it will say,
hey, there's four up and
running if I do a get pods.
Yeah, we see that, hey, the
422 ones were the older pods
that we had earlier.
Now it created these new
pods that start with 968.
And slowly it's going
to start terminating
all of the old ones.
And all the traffic
will basically
start moving to
these new 968 pods.
If I sort of
continue with that we
see that, hey, within probably
about 30 seconds or so
it's done updating.
And if I go back here again,
I should see Party People
if this demo works
correctly, and we do so.
So you can see how like using
containers, and container
development, especially
with Container Engine,
it's a lot quicker and easier
to manage your code in this way,
right?
Think about how you normally
go through a CI/CD type
of process, where maybe you
have to build with larger files.
And larger files have to get
pushed through the system.
I mean, this is a way where
containers are fairly small.
They're portable.
And you're able to get them
to the system fairly quickly.
So let's go back to
the slides right now.
And I'll show you another
demo in a moment, as well.
OK.
So the next thing.
So what we did right now was
actually pretty easy, right?
I mean it wasn't too hard to do.
We were able to use a
lot of existing tools
to create a container image.
We push it up to the registry.
We're able to get
this stuff to work.
But you know, what
about a lot of
the other common applications
that are out there, right?
So you know, let's
say you wanted to,
you know, WordPress, or
Redis, or MySQL, or Engine X.
Like, you know,
you shouldn't have
to go through kind of the work
that we did to do that, right?
There's an open
community of people
and Kubernetes is an
open source project.
So one of things we
definitely rely upon
is our open source
community to work together
to solve these types
of problems ourselves.
So really what I want to do is,
you know, if you remember back
to the days where you
were installing software
on a typical Linux box.
Maybe at first you
had to take a tarball.
You had to un-tar it.
You had to try to make it.
And you know, sometimes
you ran into errors.
Like, you know, library
dependency type errors,
and things like that.
And it was really annoying.
And really, what kind
of helped with that
was package managers, right?
Like YUM, and APT-Get, and
those kinds of things came out.
And it made the installation
of software a lot easier
in those boxes.
Now, in Kubernetes the container
stuff that we sort of walked
through earlier
was like, hey, this
is how you build a
container from scratch.
But we wanted to build a
package manager as well.
So Helm is the package
manager for Kubernetes.
And it really makes it easy
for you to start up, and build,
and run containers that are
most common in the marketplace,
right?
So this is an overview on Helm.
Helm runs a set of files
called Helm Charts.
And they contain the
application definitions
that are necessary
for the Helm install.
So as I mentioned
earlier, Helm's
the Kubernetes package manager.
Makes it very easy to
install many of the most
common applications.
The list of generally
available helm charts,
we have over 50 today.
And those are the stable charts.
We also have a lot
of incubator charts
that are still in progress.
So it's a growing list that
we've been talking about.
And you know,
specifically there's
one project that
we've been working
on that's actually getting
ready for an alpha release
right now, right?
And this is SPARC, right?
So today users have had
to run big data workloads
on standalone SPARC
servers, or they
had to run SPARC
on yarn clusters,
or they had to run these
on Mesos clusters, right?
The community has been hard at
work with SPARC integration,
and Kubernetes is
giving users the option
to run their big data
jobs in Kubernetes, right?
So we had SPARC running in
standalone mode in Kubernetes
last year.
You can manually
launch a SPARC master.
You can launch SPARC workers.
And you can do these by hand.
But the architecture
didn't really
fully integrate with
Kubernetes for all
of the resource scheduling.
So the alpha that's
being ready to be
released right now directly
integrates with Kubernetes.
Launches executers
via a SPARC driver.
So it really scales up,
and it takes advantage
of all the
orchestration management
that Kubernetes is
so good at doing.
So I mean, this is
a great first step
to enable big data SPARC
workloads to work on Kubernetes
and to let users of
big data move off
of the isolated clusters that
you may have onto a shared
infrastructure with
the other applications
that you run in
Kubernetes, right?
Ultimately, we want to
see new things enabled
by having big data
closely integrated
with modern microservices-based
applications, all
of these things
running in Kubernetes.
So the community
is hard at work.
And the community that's largely
been responsible for SPARC
at Kubernetes
includes developers
from a wide range of companies.
I mean, there are developers
from Palantir, Google,
Pepperdata, Intel, Redhead,
Holloway, many others.
So this is, like I said,
it's alpha ready very soon.
If you're interested
in trying this out,
and if you're a company
that uses a lot of SPARC,
and you want to try running
SPARC on Kubernetes,
go to that link up there,
and try downloading it,
and play with it, because
this is really the way
that we start getting
applications running
within Kubernetes,
and in containers,
and they eventually
become Helm charts,
and then the whole community
benefits from that.
So why should you
use Helm, right?
So Helm is easy to
use because much
of the work in
getting the container
is already done for you, right?
So you should use Helm
because it's really fast.
It's convenient.
It's reliable.
There's no reason to reinvent
the wheel when someone else is
in the community has already
done a lot of that work for,
you right?
And you know, because we are
a community, if you don't
see a Helm chart for a piece
of software that's fairly
commonplace, go build it.
Build one.
Contribute to the community.
And now everyone else will
have that Helm chart available.
So we've been emphasizing
this whole community
aspect of Helm a lot.
And just, I think,
three months ago
there were only like 10 charts
out there that were stable.
And now there's over 50.
So you know, it's
really worked, in terms
of bringing this
community together
to help get containerized
applications up and running.
So let's take a quick look.
I mean, we're going to
do a quick demo on Helm.
And I'll show you how quickly
and easily we can actually get
Helm up and running, all right?
Let me get the command up.
So that's all Helm.
I'm actually going to install
this by using Helm Redis.
So we'll clear that up.
So this is basically the only
command that you need to run.
So hey, believe it or not,
like that one command, Helm,
this command right
here, Helm install
dash dash name via stable Redis
is really all we need to do.
And Redis is actually
installed right now.
To kind of prove that I'll
do a kube control get pods.
And we see our old Hello
notice still running up there,
but we also have this
my Redis node that's
being created right now, right?
So if we wait a little
bit that will come up.
The instructions that
it came up with here
was, you know, to get
your password do that.
You know, it says Redis can
be accessed via that port.
And then that's
your cluster there.
To connect, copy and
paste these things.
So I'll get my Redis password.
Since it tells me to
run this I'll run that.
So I'll run that.
And there.
I guess that gave me
my Redis password.
Yeah.
The pod itself is now running.
So it took less than a minute
to get that pod up and running.
To connect to you
Redis server, it
says just got to this kube
control and go to this.
So I'll do that.
So that is actually connecting
me to Redis that's running.
And then to log in,
or to connect to Redis
through the command
line, it says to do this.
So I'll just follow
instructions and do that, right?
So we're actually in a
Redis instance right now.
To sort of prove
that, for anyone
who is fairly
well-versed in Redis
I'll do a couple of
quick commands here.
So I'll set temp to--
is that not coming up?
OK.
There it is.
So I'll set temp to GCP Next.
So I set up a name value--
So Redis, for those
who aren't aware,
it's a simple, noSQL, noSQL
database, name value pairs.
So I set up a name of temp
to have value GCP Next.
So if I get the value of
temp it pulls GCP Next.
It's really wonderful.
All it really does.
If I set a variable like x to
10 then I can increment it.
You know, and keeping
incrementing it.
And, you know, if I
get x, you know, well--
so I get stuff like that.
If I exit out of this stuff,
we have Redis up and running.
So essentially what I was
trying to prove to you
is that, hey, we have Redis
sort of up and running,
and we have an actual instance
of Redis up and running.
And instead of going
through a lot of the work
that we did earlier with
building the container, instead
all I did here was I
did the Helm install.
And that was really all it
took to get up and running.
So if you want to get started
with container development,
yeah, take your
existing applications,
you know, containerize them, and
run them in Container Engine.
But if you want to build
a WordPress instance,
for example, quickly just
do that do that in Helm.
The various charts
are available.
We can just do a Helm search.
And this list here are all
of the currently stable Helm
charts.
So you can kind
of see that a lot
of the sort of
typical applications
that you might
want are in there.
Because the list
is getting really,
pretty big you can also
do a search, and say,
hey, I want anything that
has the keyboard Redis in it.
And it'll give me the
stable charts for Redis.
So that's essentially
how we use Helm charts.
I think we can move back to
the actual presence, the slides
again.
So that was Helm.
So our first hello
world application
was pretty easy, right?
And using Helm Charts
was pretty easy.
It was pretty easy
to build a container.
We push it up to
container registry.
We ran it in Container Engine.
You know, using Helm we
were able to containerize
a lot of the common
applications.
But as you start writing
more and more applications,
and using containers,
your application
will likely start
getting a lot more
complex than kind of the
examples I gave today, right?
Inevitably you'll
come across a need
where you need to
start sharing data.
You need to mount volumes
across multiple pods.
So this is where
persistent volumes comes.
And I did want to
talk through how
we use persistent
volumes in Kubernetes.
So let's start with
identifying the problem
that we're trying to solve.
So first, we have this basic
unit of scheduling Kubernetes,
which is a pod, right?
So in Kubernetes, looking
at Kubernetes' concepts
for a second, we had containers
that we built earlier,
and containers in Kubernetes
are organized in pods.
A pod consists of one or
more containers, right?
And typically when you have a
container it doesn't actually
share its file system
with anybody else, right?
So things normally don't
show their file system,
but you have a pod that has
multiple containers in it.
And when you start
organizing your pods,
like, well, one of the
questions I do get sometimes
is well, which containers
should be inside a pod?
And it kind of depends on you.
Like if you want to
start sharing things,
like, that's the same network,
you want to guarantee that it's
going to be running on the same
node then, yeah, share these.
And some examples might be if
you have an Engine X container,
and then if you're
running a PHP application,
so you have a PHP container.
Might want to combine
those two because you're
going to sort of scale them up
appropriately at the same time.
But if you had, like, a database
container and a front end
container, you may
not, because you
might want to scale your
databases differently
than your front end, right?
So what that we've
looked at here
is that pods are composed of
these multiple containers.
But it would be really nice
if these different containers
within a pod could still
share the same value,
you know, for speed, and for
a lot of different purposes,
right?
So the second thing is that
containers are ephemeral,
right?
Like we saw when we did
the replications over there
that we had four, and whenever
I updated code all it really did
was brought up four new pods.
And it just killed
the old ones, right?
So these pods are these
short-lived units of work.
And imagine if there's
like a piece of storage
attached to that, right?
So this means that if
that container crashed
or the machine is
restarted then you end up
losing all of your data, right?
So you know, with the Hello
World app that we had,
we didn't really use data.
So it didn't really matter.
But you know, for a
more complex application
that uses data back and
forth, like this, can
be a big problem.
And you know, if you imagine
trying to run applications
such as like a stateful
type of application,
whether it be a database or
some other larger application
like that, I mean, having
your data disappear
is just a nonstarter, right?
Like, it's not going to
work for what we want to do.
So those are the problems.
And this is where Kubernetes
volumes comes in, right?
So at its core a volume
is just a directory,
that you could pre-populate
some data in it.
And that's accessible to all
the different containers that
are within a pod, right?
And how that directory comes
to be in the medium that
backs it up the
contents, what happens
after a pod's terminated?
Those are all sort of
implementation details
that we'll talk about.
But it depends on
the type of volume.
And you can configure
all of that.
If we take a closer look
at this, like, Kubernetes,
the volume plugins can
be largely categorized
into two types.
So the first type are
the persistent volumes.
And, you know, there's
obviously a lot
of support for a lot of
different persistent volumes
out there, right?
So these are storage
that outlives
the lifecycle of a pod.
So in other words, it could
be anything from an NFS Share
that you see up there.
Could be a cloud provider
with virtual disks.
So lifecycle of storage is
independent from the lifecycle
of the pod, right?
So if the pod dies the
storage is still alive.
And so that's great.
So if a pod referencing one
of these volumes is created,
storage is made available
inside it, it's attached,
it's mounted.
But then, when the
pod's terminated volumes
are unmounted,
could be detached,
but the data's always
still there, right?
So the key is the data persists.
So if another pod comes along,
references the same storage
volume, with the
same mount point,
then that storage will
still have the data there.
So it's pretty convenient to be
able to have a persistent data
store, right?
The ephemeral side
are what we've
been talking about
till now, and is
what's used in pods,
and in a lot of volumes
today, where as soon
as the pod's created,
you create this volume.
But then when the pod's
deleted the volume
just disappears, right?
So it's usually a scratch
space, a shared space.
And it's a space that could be
shared between the containers
and a pod.
But it's going to go away.
So the type of data that
you would put in there
is usually temporary type data.
So let's walk through an
example to help sort of clarify
a lot of this, right?
So here we have a pod.
Pod, as we said earlier,
the basic unit of scheduling
Kubernetes.
Contains one or more containers.
And in this case, we
have a single container.
We called it Sleepy
Container here.
And that's the Google
Container Registry image there.
It's just a container that
kind of sleeps, is really
all it does.
But if we look at how to set
up storage for this container,
well, we configure
storage there, right?
In this case we used a Google
Compute Engine persistent disk.
We called it Panda Disk.
And what this file here assumes
is that disk has already
been procured.
It's already there.
Supposing like that this disk
already exists someplace,
and this is going to
reference it, right?
So it's referencing
it directly, right?
So then the pod also defines
where we should mount that disk
that we saw, right?
So in this example, all
we did was just said,
hey, we want to
mount that volume
data that we see up there, that
Panda Disk, over to slash data.
Seems pretty trivial.
But there's actually a lot
going on under the scenes.
One of the concepts
with Kubernetes
is you have these notes
that are running pods.
And so when your pod
is attached to a node,
then Kubernetes knows to
make an API call to say,
hey, where is this
persistent disk?
It attaches that persistent
disk to that node, which
then attaches it to your pod.
Now, one of the things
that Kubernetes also
can do very well, and is
a power of Kubernetes,
is if a node is having issues
then it will create a new node,
and it'll drain out that
node, and your pod will get
moved to another node, right?
It automatically sort of
handles all that for you.
So typically most
Kubernetes developers
don't really care where
your containers are running.
As long as it's
running somewhere.
So in that sense, your pod
might be moved to a new node.
And when it does that,
Kubernetes is smart enough
to automatically
detect that change,
detach this from the first
node that was having a problem,
attach it to this other
node, and any time
your pod sort of moves nodes
your volumes will always
follow it and
Kubernetes always knows
to make sure that it tracks
it, and attaches it to the node
itself.
So there's lots sort of going
on under the scenes in there.
And Kubernetes
takes care of this
but, you know, I mean,
this is pretty cool,
and it works, but
we can actually
do a lot better than this.
And that's really what
persistent volumes is.
Persistent volumes
is what Kubernetes
does to manage volumes.
And it's a little bit better
than what we just looked at.
Persistent volumes, it's
an abstract storage layer
that is used and
managed by Kubernetes.
So the way to describe this is
we have two different roles.
They could be the same person
within your organization.
We have this first role that's
is cluster administrator that
creates a number of persistent
volumes that are available.
So the admin provisions them.
And then we have users
that claim the volumes
that they want to use.
So in some ways,
it's similar to how
like an admin might create a
cluster with a bunch of nodes,
and then users say, I want
replicas and pods running.
And you know,
they'll automatically
get assigned to these nodes.
So in that sense a
user says, I need,
you know, say, 100 gigabytes.
And if there's no gigabytes
available in any volume
then it will get
assigned to that, right?
So in static
provisioning, you know,
that's a fairly simple use case.
And that if you make a claim
and there's a preview available
it'll attach it to that.
Dynamic provisioning,
which I'm going
to go into a little
more detail later,
works through a thing
called StorageClass.
But that's actually
pretty cool because,
hey, we all sort
of work and live
in this world of
cloud now, right?
Does it really
make a lot of sense
to sort of pre-provision
storage that's available
when, ideally what you
would do is a user says,
I need 100 gigs.
We don't say, hey, is there a
100-gig volume available for me
to attach to this user?
Instead you say,
well, OK, I'm going
to go out and get
100 gigs for you now.
Find the storage for you
somewhere in the cloud.
And then attach it, right?
So that's where dynamic
provision comes in.
And it's a new sort
of unique feature
that's within Kubernetes.
You know we alpha
launched it in 1.2.
We beta launched it at 1.4.
We're ready to
make this generally
available with 1.6, which is
ready to launch in a few weeks.
At the end of March is when
the 1.6 release date is.
And that's when dynamic
provisioning will be available
as well.
So let's walk through
this a little bit.
So this is a simple case of
static provision and release.
So we start here with the
cluster administrator.
This is what a yaml file looks
like for the persistent volume.
You know, we see
here that there's two
that they have assigned.
One is a 10-gig volume there.
And then we have another
one that's 100 gigs.
So the cluster
administrator said, hey,
these are the persistent
volumes that I have available.
There's two for you, right?
And if you run that kube
control create command
on that yaml file, and then
you run a get PV it says,
hey, these are the two
statuses available.
So they're not actually
assigned to anybody.
So you know, pretty
straightforward.
Someone basically
said, hey, I have
these two volumes available
for anyone to use, right?
So in other words, the
cluster administrator
creates a persistent value, and
makes some available for use.
Now we have this user
that comes along.
And the user creates what we
call a persistent volume claim,
right?
This user is saying, hey I
have a persistent volume claim
that I'd like to have.
I need 100 gigs of storage.
So this is the claim
that they're making.
And so we have a
couple of things here.
We have the persistent volume
that was assigned to that yaml.
Here we have a persistent
volume claim that's
being made against that, right?
So the user creates a
persistent volume claim.
And now if we take a step back
and look at what happened,
well, first we ran
the persistent volume,
and created the two
volumes that we saw.
Next we created the
persistent volume claim.
And now if we do a
kube control get PVs
we see that, hey, you know
the claim was for 100 gigs.
So we see that the 100 gig
that was created is now bound
and it's claimed by
that claim, which
is the test that has my PVC.
So here we've statically
bound the claim together.
So if another user comes along
with another claim for 100 gigs
this is not available to that
user at that point, right?
So the binder works to
actually make that match.
And you know, it's fairly
straightforward in this case.
Like they need 100
gig, and there happened
to be 100 gigs available.
So it was made available there.
So now we end up sort
of with this happy state
where the user then creates
a pod and in the pod
they say which claim they want.
And I think I have an example
of that yaml file as well.
And this is what
that looks like.
So the pod that we had
before, if you remember,
it's had that GCE persistent
disk, that Panda disk.
So at that point we had
to make this assumption
that Panda disk already exists.
And that it's already
been procured.
And it's already been set up.
We've abstracted this
now to say, well,
we don't have to make
that assumption anymore.
All we're saying is that we
have this PV claim that we want,
and so we know that in
this other yaml file
we had identified the
PV claim to be 100 gigs.
And so all we're saying
here is I need that.
I reference a claim.
So this pod is now
referencing the claim itself.
And it's no longer
referencing the actual sort
of mounted piece of persistent
disk that we needed.
So this is a lot better
than what we had before,
because now we've sort
of abstracted this out.
You can take this file,
move it to any other server,
and as long as you
reference the claim then it
all it'll just find a disk.
If Panda disk were to
go away and get deleted,
like all your pods
that are referencing
it won't start breaking, right?
In this case.
Because the claim can get
moved from one PV to another PV
fairly easily.
So what we kind
of saw here was we
have a pod that
referenced that claim.
The name is also tied to
the persistent volume.
And so the example
here is, let's say
the pod writes a piece of data.
So now we have that
little star in that folder
up there because we have
a specific piece of data
that was written by that pod
through the persistent volume
claim to the persistent
volume, right?
But now let's get a
little bit interesting
here where the user says,
well, I want to delete the pod.
I don't want the pod anymore.
So if the user goes out and
actually deletes this pod,
well, what happens, right?
Well, really, I mean, nothing
really happens in a sense,
because, as I mentioned
earlier, we have pods,
and we have persistent
volume claims,
and then we have
persistent volumes.
The persistent claim and
the persistent volume
is still bound together, right?
The pod referenced the claim.
But if the pod is
gone, then fine.
There's no reference
to the claim.
But the claim itself is
still tied to the volume.
So the data doesn't go away.
And the claim is
still sitting there.
We just don't have any pods that
are using that claim, right?
So that's really
what this illustrates
is that the pod may go away,
but the persistent volume claim
is still sitting there.
It's still bound to the
same persistent volume
that we had before.
And the data is still
not lost, right?
And then let's say a user
creates a new pod again,
and is referencing--
could be another pod,
could be the same pod
that they bring up again.
As long as it references
that same my PVC, which
is the PV claim, then it will
attach to that same piece
of persistent volume again.
So now we're sort of
back to our happy state
again where we were before,
where the pods were restarted,
new pods came up, yet the
data has never been lost.
So that's pretty cool.
All right.
And that's really the state
that we have here, again, right?
But let's get a little
bit more fancy now.
And let's delete the pod.
So let's say the
user deletes the pod.
And let's also say the
user deleted the claim.
Now we have an
issue here, right?
Because while the
claim itself is gone,
so now it's no longer bound,
so if we did a kube control get
PV, that 100-gig volume
that was bound before
is no longer bound anymore.
So the data itself at this
point is actually deleted.
So there are a couple of ways
that we can reclaim data here.
The default way
is we recycle it.
I mean, essentially, behind this
scenes, like it does an RM dash
RF of all the data in there.
So the data is gone, right?
From that perspective.
And then it's going to be made
available to other claims that
decide to use that, right?
So that's essentially what
happens to that volume,
in that sense.
So that's really kind
of the static case
that we had with
static provisioning
of persistent volumes and
persistent volume claims.
Now, I did mention
earlier that, you know, we
have dynamic provision, right?
So it's pretty cool.
It's late-breaking type stuff.
I mean, this is stuff that's
coming out in Kubernetes.
It's generally available,
you know, in a few weeks.
And you know, and
like I said earlier,
like living in the
world of cloud,
like we shouldn't have to
pre-provision volumes anymore,
right?
I mean, that's something that
maybe we had to do years ago,
where, you know, you had
someone that was setting up
these persistent volumes saying,
somebody might come along,
and they might need
10, 100, 500 gigs,
and I'm just going to
allocate a bunch them
available for my users to use.
Well, rather than
having that paradigm,
like we should be
able to go through,
and it should be all
on demand now, right?
Like if a user says
whatever they need,
you know, should be able to make
API calls to a cloud storage
type of provider, and
dynamically, you know,
build a volume, and then
attach to that person.
And this isn't only cloud.
It can work within
an organization
that uses NSF mount.
It's like you might have storage
available that you can then
create the right amount
of storage available,
and then mount it for them.
Like that's fine, too, even if
you're not within Cloud, right?
But you shouldn't have to
pre-provision everything just
in the chance that someone's
going to ask for it.
So that's really what
dynamic provisioning is here
to address.
Now, the key concept
with dynamic provisioning
is that it uses what's called
the storage class, right?
So in the example here we set up
two different storage classes.
We set up a storage class for
slow, which is essentially
it's a sort of regular disk.
It's PV standard.
And in the case here,
with the provisioner
is we set it to be
Kubernetes IO, GCEPD.
So it's a Google Compute
Engine Persistent Disk.
The parameter
section in this file,
essentially, it's
just like a large sort
of blob name, value per
blob, that we just pass on
to whoever the provisioner is.
So essentially, the reason
why that's important
is because whether that's
a Google Compute Engine
Persistent Disk, or
any other provider,
that parameters section,
you can put whatever
you want in there
depending on whatever
the provider is expecting.
So if the provider decides
to update their parameters
with some new stuff, you
can just add it in there.
And it automatically
will be updated.
There's no need to
update Kubernetes,
or anything like that.
And in this case, we set
up a slower one for that.
And then we have an SSD on
the bottom, which is fast.
You know, so essentially
the cluster administrator--
and like I said earlier,
the cluster administrator
and the user might
be the same person.
There's no necessarily need
for them to be different.
But in the example here
they're different roles.
So in this case they've
set up a slow and a fast.
And to the users they're telling
them, hey, if you want storage
and you want to dynamically
provision it, tell me.
If you want slow storage,
or fast storage, right?
And it depends on what
it is you need, right?
Maybe if it's like some logging
of all the traffic that's
coming in, slow is fine, right?
But if you want something that
is going to react a lot faster
where performance is
much more important,
maybe you want
something that's fast.
But you leave it up to the
developer to choose that,
right?
So that's what that looks like.
And with dynamic
provisioning the users
now consume storage the same
way that they did before.
But instead of in the
claim saying, well,
just how big it is,
we had this new thing
added that says
storage class name.
And here we said fast, right?
So if we don't have
that storage class name,
then it'll just look for any
existing statically assignable
persistent volumes.
But if we have that storage
class name in there,
then it's going to look for this
in the storage class portion
that we looked at earlier,
to make sure that's there.
There was a change made between
Kubernetes version 1.5 and 1.6.
And that's why it looks a
little bit different there.
But you know, 1.6
is the new version.
And that's where
we made that change
to say storage
class name, instead
of that volume.beta storage
class thing that we had before.
So that's really how
dynamic provisioning works.
It's really kind of the
next step into what we're
doing with volumes.
So if this stuff was
pretty interesting to you,
and I hope it really was, please
get involved in community.
The Slack channel is up there.
The GitHub code
repository is over there.
It's open source.
So anybody can go into
that code depository.
You can download Kubernetes.
You can try it out.
You can also be a
contributor as well.
So you know, the Slack
channel especially
is full of people all day
long talking about Kubernetes.
So you know, if
that's your interests,
and there are a lot of
minded folks over there.
So it's a pretty
interesting group.
Now, also-- there it is.
So there are a couple
other talks here.
Hopefully you're signed
up for some of them.
Right after this
talk, across the hall,
Kelsey Hightower's
basically taking this talk
to the next level.
Like, you know, we talked
about creating a container,
building it, running it.
He's talking about,
well what would you
do if you wanted to run that
container in a production
environment?
So he talks a lot about
securing that container.
Some of the name spaces
that we want to use.
Liveness checks to make
sure your containers are
always up and running.
Things like
auto-scaling your pods
so that you don't
have to sit there
if you get a sudden spike
in traffic, you know,
middle of the night,
you're not getting paged.
The system's auto-scaling
everything for you, right?
So he's really talking about
how to take your containers
from development,
which we talked about,
into actual production.
There's also some more about
like Container Engine today,
as well as tomorrow as well.
I think I talked about
this a little bit earlier.
But upstairs on the third
floor we have Whack-A-Pod.
We also have Meet
the Experts up there.
If you have any
further questions,
can also talk to me
at any time as well.
Again, my name is Dan Paik.
And I'm one of the product
managers on the team.
And Whack-A-Pod's
a pretty fun game
you can play up there, where
we have nine pods running.
As you start whacking
each one the pods go down.
We basically delete the pod.
But Kubernetes will keep
bringing them back up again.
So you can see that,
you know, it's possible
if you're really fast to
bring your application down.
But it's usually not down
for more than a second or so
as it keeps coming up.
And the Node.js code app that
we went over earlier today
at the first part
of this, the link
is over there if you want
to take a look at that.
If you wanted to run
that yourself at home,
and play with it in a Container
Engine you can always do that.
It's free to do if you wanted
to play around with that.
So that's really kind of what I
wanted to talk to you all about
today.
I wanted to make sure I
left about 15 minutes or so
for questions.
So if there are any questions
I'm always happy to take them.
Hopefully I can answer them.
But yeah, so there
are two mics out there
if anyone has questions.
Or if not, you can always feel
free to walk up and talk to me
as well.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]